[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
معلومات السريه او الاستخبارات هي نفس
الكلمه بالصينيه الذي هم كلمه واحده او هي
محفوفه بالكثير من المشاكل من ضمنها الضعف
السياق
والمعلومات المظلله والابلاغ الدائري وحتى
الخداع شاهدته حالات حيث بعض العملاء
يبيعون معلومات يدعون انها سريه ولكنهم في
الحقيقه حصلوا عليها مكتوبه في مقالات
الصحفيه كتبت باللغه لا يستطيع الضربه
قراءتها او يفهمها
لا المعلومات السريه ولا المسار مفتوح
يمكنك
موثوقه وحتى حينها بالنسبه الموثوقيه يجب
ان نتاكد منها وهنا ياتي دور الضباط
الاستخبارات
[موسيقى]
استخدام كلمه المصادر المفتوحه
والمصطلح الدرجه الان هو المعلومات
المتاحه للعامه ولكن هذا المصطلح يعطينا
مفهوما عن طبيعتها استطيع ان اذكر لك
قائمه طويله من المصادر او لكن الابسط ان
نفكر في الامر على اهم المسار المفتوحي
المعلومات عامه المتاحه
قانونيا ومجانا او فقط مجانا وحسب مجالي
والذي
هو من اختصاصي
التكنولوجيا فالنسبه 85% قد تصل الى مئه
بالمئه اي العملات استخباراتيه جمع
المعلومات العلميه والتكنولوجيه والعلماء
حول العالم يسرهم التحدث عن اعمالي مو
انجازاتهم ومن هنا نجمع هذه المعلومات
وحتى الوكالات المموله ايضا
تعلن المنح ولمن تمنحها وهذه ايضا مصدرا
جيد للمعلومات استخباراتيه لجمع المعلومات
العلميه والتكنولوجيا
[موسيقى]